what's the difference between dogecoin  and the dow maker coin dogecoin is a  fork a copy paste of bitcoin it can't do  much right it can just be a coin dao  maker is built on ethereum so we're  piggybacking the security theorem  dogecoin has its own thing it's own  security right it's all miners etc  dogecoin is meant as a currency whereas  downmaker is meant as a tokenized share  of the dalmac company dowmaker has  benefits you know our coin gives you  certain benefits if you own these coins  for example you own this coin you have a  chance of getting into these sales which  generally make money not all of them  they're risky but in the bull market  generally speaking they all make money  dogecoin gives you no benefits right it  just goes up feed on truths about it